منذ سنوات والعراق يعاني من انخفاض
المتواصل في الايرادات المائيه عبر نهري
دجله والفرات وتحديدا في محافظه النجف
الواقعه في الجنوب الغربي للعاصمه بغداد
المحافظه التي كانت تعرف لدى الجميع بانها
المنطقه الغنيه بالمياه والتي كان بامكان
سكانها الوصول الى المياه العذبه من
الابار للحفاظ على الثروه السمكيه
اما الان فقد انعكس الوضع تماما
وتسبب ركود المياه والجفاف فيها الى
انتشار الامراض الفتاكه التي ساهمت في
انخفاض الانتاج السمكيه
جفاف المياه يعني زادت الامراض علينا من
زادت الامراض الاسماك تمرضت يعني
فانتاجيت قلت شوف ان كانت الانهار شويه
ميه مرتفع ومجاري مثل ما نقول احنا نعبر
عليه يعني كان وصلنا مي عزب بالابار
مالتنا كان نقدر نستفاد من الماء
شوي شوي قام يصعد الكبريت عدنا بالماء
ماله البيض وهذا سببها لاكات
السبب الرئيسي ويعود الى انخفاض التدفقات
من ايران وتركيا والتي كانت تصدر حوالي
70% من نهرين دجله والفرات واصبح الجفاف
والعواصف الرمليه ودرجات الحراره العاليه
تشكل تهديدا وجودا لدى العراقيين بشكل
متزايد
فانتاج الاسماك في محافظه النجف قد بلغ
نحو البيت من سنويا في عام 2018
وهو الامر الذي ادى بطبيعه الحال الى نقص
الاسماك في السوق وارتفاع اسعارها بشكل
مبالغ وتوقف بعض المزارعين عن العمل
تاكل ثلاث مرات بالشهر
يعني
بدل ما كنا احنا كنا 20 20 طن او 40 طن
صار صار ما يسدد حتى
سعر الاسماك اللي تجيبه فاحنا
بالله قلت من قبل الانتاج توقفنا عن العمل
وقد احتجت بغداد مرارا على هذه السدود على
نهري الفرات ودجله التي يعتمد عليها
العراق في تامين المياه كما فاق ما ازمه
شح المياه تدني كميات الامطار على مدى
السنوات الماضيه بسبب التغير المناخي
سلطان العربيه